that looks muddy because I am listen I
had a whole other video I had planned on
editing for you guys today but I'm gonna
save it for a couple days down the line
because I just experienced something
very traumatic that I think a lot of us
have experienced I had a lunch meeting
today and it went very well and I
realized it on my way home from the
lunch meeting I was gonna be passing by
a target I love a good target like the
next but I also recently got back from
traveling and there are a lot of odds
and ends that I needed to pick up so I
thought this was perfect and I got into
target and of course I get very
overwhelmed by all the new goddamn Nate
Berkus designs but I'm in a zone of
getting things I needed getting things I
forgot I needed getting things I don't
totally need but I'm really good at
telling myself I shouldn't need and then
all sudden when I'm right in the middle
of my groove it hits me oh my god I have
to [ __ ] so bad where did I come from
that shouldn't have happened that
already happened this morning like body
what's going on yeah you have the right
to free speech but you talked a lot this
morning so make all my purchases as fast
as possible and I think to myself I I
can make it home and thus begins the
traumatic experience that I wanted to
share with you guys today trying to
drive home well desperately needing to
take a [ __ ] oh it's an awful experience
spoiler alert there was no tragic ending
I made it home in time however the
experience of driving while you have to
shoot it's quite a unique experience and
I wanted to talk to you guys about today
because I'm sure one of you out there
has had that experience when you're
driving and you have to to everyone
around me becomes an enemy and everyone
around me I feel like he's personally
trying to keep me from getting to my
toilet I have never understood video
games until that very moment everything
becomes Grand Theft Auto I have never
become a more hateful person I was
behind a Range Rover
and I was just yelling such awful things
at this Range Rover very similar to it
could have been a Range Rover full of
well behaved optimistic intelligent
children and I hated it
which leads me to the fact that your
brain is a crazy place when you start to
feel desperate or panicked when you just
use your car your brain starts creating
all sorts of scenarios in which that's
okay it's how I assume MacGyver's brain
works where you look around your car and
every normal seeming thing becomes
something else to you it becomes a
device for holding [ __ ] a device for
funneling [ __ ]
a device for cleaning up [ __ ] a possible
new pair of pants that CVS bag can be
underwear my brain at least starts to
think about if I did actually [ __ ] my
pants what do I do
how do I actually get from my car to my
house how do I clean this how can I
blame this on my dog I gotta have a dog
oh is that the reason people get dogs
also I turn the radio on to try and
distract myself and listen to music so I
don't think physically about what's
happening in my body but somehow every
song seems to have a much closer
connection to your actual moment than it
did before you play you man I could show
you incredible things you care to see
that I just [ __ ] my pants it's pretty
incredible but only if you Church has a
bathroom what I say the police officer
when he pulls me over for speeding and
doesn't believe that I was going so fast
because I had to get to a restroom Oh
believe me just watch
you asked for it and the radio is a
great way to distract you but another
great way to distract you from [ __ ]
your pants while driving our audiobooks
audible.com slash Grace we've talked
about this before but in case you don't
know audible.com is a hub of over
150,000 audiobooks and you can download
one for free by signing up using
audible.com slash grace I highly
recommend yes please Amy Poehler's new
book it is a great book and then the
audiobook version is insane because she
has all these guests come and read
things so it's like an they call it a
dinner party as an audiobook it's really
really cool so make sure you go to
audible.com such grace to download your
free audio book that might save you next
time you've come close to poo I'm sure
audible will love this plug now back to
the more important issue one of the
worst parts about trying to get home
when you have two especially in Los
Angeles is that lots of people dogs you
just drive by watching dogs openly [ __ ]
all over curbs grass tree people and
it's so confusing to watch for the body
when you have to take whatever I flew
into our driveway and running into my
house as if I'm being chased by
Slenderman but then once you do make it
on time girl says - hallelujah I don't
know oh God
there's no real reason for this video
other than I just had a traumatic
experience and wanted to share it that's
what the Internet's for right ships um
giggles